we know for sure that season 8 has
already been written and passed on to
producers what we do not know me as if
these like scripts are true or not I
will point out any potential sentence
that might seem to be out of the order
as I did in my previous video regarding
the leaks for the season premiere
anyways if you don't want anything to be
potentially spoiled it's time for you to
close this video there stated that the
first scene will take place in the Great
Hall of Winterfell John the near styrian
Davos and sense are present here ginjury
enthronement all the rest that walk has
fallen and the Night Watch has been
destroyed tormund also mentions that the
night king rides the undead dragon bran
stark confirms these statements and
tells that the night king is on his way
to Winterfell in case you don't remember
through his flock of Ravens at east
watch Ben also was night king knocked
down a portion of the wall Jon Snow
tells the rest that they have no time to
lose and asks master Vulcan to inform
all of their banners everyone in the
north to prepare themselves for a war
against the army of the Dead they need
to prepare for an attack at the
battlefield of Winterfell after having
to process a lot of new information that
bran revealed to him in the season
premiere and struggling with his
identity Jon Snow goes to the crypts to
visit his mother Lina and his uncle Ned
Stark Daenerys notices that there's
something wrong with Jon and finds him
in the crypts she asks Jon what's wrong
with him Jon tells her that his name is
not even Jon Snow
he calls Jon Snow a lie people have made
him believe all his life Daenerys is
confused and asks John for clarification
but John walks away from her
Daenerys notices the John behaves aloof
towards her the nearest walks out of the
crypts with Jorah notices he asks her
what happened out there in the crypts
and the nearest answers that she doesn't
know what's up with Jon she told juror
that John is hiding something from her
Jerell so tells the news that it struck
him that the knee risk has been so
absent for days she answers that she's
not feeling very well lately Jorah
proposes to have her examined by maester
wolkan then the scene switches to King's
Landing
Qyburn enters his chambers he mentions
that she has not spoken about her
miscarriage and that she needs to take
enough time to rest search the answers
that there is no time for that and
doesn't want to say more about the
miscarriage
Qyburn leaves her chambers Cersei
watches from her window with the singing
of the snow falls in the King's Landing
searches miscarriage was expected to
take place in the season 7 finale but it
seems it will apparently take place of
screen the next shot is showing Jaime
riding his horse in snowy conditions he
and bran
in the first episode arriving river on
both discovered that the tallest er
laying siege to Riverrun Jaime enters
the stage and Mitsuba tadmur at myrtles
Jaime he should have him in Chains but
Jaime responds that he did not come to
argue about the castle he proposes that
near to help his nieces and nephews in
the great war against the night king
Jaime also promises to give river run
back to the Tally's since it does not
matter any longer who's holding the
castle at this point admir tends to
agree not for Jaime but for his family
then we are going back to Winterfell
most of how Stark's Bannerman and the
nears his armies have now arrived in
Winterfell
among them is Howland Reed he arrived at
his army and me read by his side let me
just say that we've all been waiting for
quite some time for Howland to finally
appear in the current timeline beside
bran he's the only person that witnessed
John's birth and therefore he still has
a big role to play in one of my videos
published a few months ago I predicted
that we would most likely learn that Jon
Snow is an effect legitimate son of
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark which
we did in bronze flashback Jon Snow on
the other hand would learn the truth in
the final season and even though he
might not entirely believe in bronze
words Howland Reed would then appear and
not only that he would confirm it but
there's also possibility that he would
prove it with some object related to his
show parentage even George RR Martin's
stated that Howland Reed will eventually
appear anyways sorry there receives a
visitor in Winterfell he seems to be an
ordinary Bannerman from House sermon but
he quickly removes his face revealing
that he is actually Arya's old friend
jocking Hagar for a surprise to have
Jack and visit her hidden tells area
that the many-faced God requires another
death a name to be crossed off her list
he reveals it to be the queen of the
Seven Kingdoms Cersei Lannister
jaqen says a price was paid what better
servant of the many-faced God another
stark of Winterfell to kill Cersei
Lannister he then gives a vial of poison
to Orion leaves her Jon Snow seizes the
moment to talk with Howland Reed alone
he asks Howland to confirm brand
statement regarding his show lineage but
Howland does not acknowledge this at all
jump leads him to tell the truth since
Robert Baratheon is not alive anymore
there is no point of lying anymore
additionally House Targaryen is
currently the most powerful house in all
of the Seven Kingdoms there is no danger
for him if he truly is a Targaryen
Howland ultimately confirms that Ned was
caring Lena's child and he came out of
the tower of joy he promised to his best
friend
keep this a secret Jan tanks came for
telling the truth
even though that might not be what he
wanted to hear knowing that the army of
the undead will be upon them very soon
John and hand of the nearest Aryan with
all their advisors allies and important
people discussed together how they will
defend the north allegedly the seat of
how somber the last heart has already
been attacked by the army of the Dead
Ned umber did not make it out alive as
the furthest northern settlement in the
north it makes sense that the last heart
fell as Jon Snow remarked likely be the
first obstacle in the path of the army
of the Dead having penetrated the wall
anyways tyrion speaks for the nearest
who's absent due to illness he comes
forward with a plan to defend the north
he proposes that tormund did the track
in the unsullied attack the journalist
from the dreadfort since that's where
the night king is heading to first on
their way to Winterfell the dragons will
set the army of the dead of fire and how
Stark's Bannerman and the Knights of the
Vale will fight weakened forces at the
battlefield of Winterfell and hopefully
destroyed the night king as well John
moans Brienne and Podrick to take sense
sorry and bran with them and to leave it
Robb in the rain to do Vale since there
is no longer safe to be in Winterfell
Arya doesn't want to and claims that
she's stronger and more skilled than
most men sure on the other hand wants to
fight alongside house moment Athena
reminds him that he has betrayed his own
house verse mentions that he has also
received word from King's Landing
supposedly Queen Cersei has bought a
great army of cell swords and Euron
Greyjoy has taken storms then to install
the army there Theon please to have
storms and attacked and ginjury agrees
since it's the seat of his father's
house
John promises see own that he will help
to destroy urine and save his sister
after they deal with the night king and
his army in honor my previous videos
regarding the leaks for the season 8
premiere I explained how Theon might
have ended up at Winterfell so I'm not
going to talk about it in this one we
send a visit Daenerys in her chambers
then he tells her that maester wolkan
examine her and reveals that he
confirmed her pregnancy miss and he asks
why she's not happy done the nearest
replies that John has changed towards
her which she doesn't understand why the
free fall to the track he didn't sell it
prepared to leave Winterfell John asks
Daenerys why she did not attend this
important gathering but the nares does
not reply to that
Meera goes to say goodbye to bran in the
godswood of interval when brain starts
to behave very strangely bran reveals to
her that there
we need for any army to leave Winterfell
since the net king's army already
arrived over here and commands her to
quickly inform and warn the others
Johnny's on his way to say farewell to
his siblings when the meter runs to him
and reveals what bran has told her a
huge winter storm starts to come close
to Winterfell chaos erupts the column
ignore ten Daenerys his armies gather
outside to face the night king's army
John or sent sorry and the nears to stay
inside Winterfell and promises them that
Winterfell will not fall there steering
Robin Brent's MLG Lilian and miss sandy
also remain inside Winterfell already at
first doesn't want to but a base John
soldier sense asks Mira to get brain
inside as soon as possible
a huge horde of White's invade the
battlefield of interval did the Trekkie
face the army of the Dead first and many
of them are taken out quite easily those
fights with John and says him at one
point from a white Walker trying to kill
him
ghost is killed off while saving John
inside Winterfell Daenerys is frustrated
that she's not able to help and
considers if she should fly dragon to
destroy the undead its end the answer is
that it's not wise to join the fight
while she's pregnant same on the other
hand tries to comfort Gillian little Sam
just and it seems the living side might
lose this battle John comes out of
nowhere and burns quite a lot of whites
including an undead giant but also kills
some of the northern soldiers in the
process the White Walkers bringing even
more whites also enter the stage with
the night king flying undead vissarion
about them vissarion starts the burn -
living side Lord glower Howland Reed and
tormund are burnt alive by vissarion's
blow fire
Nina wants bran to leave the godswood
but he tells her that he has to help
John brain is trying to take control
over a girl using his mind Miller warns
bran that's too dangerous and that he
should stay inside
Johnson Daenerys his army start
diminishing greatly since the army of
the Dead just keeps coming the White
Walkers tried to invade Winterfell gray
born faces - White Walkers and is able
to take out one of them with his spear
made from dragon glass but the other one
kills him the White Walkers supposedly
tried to invade Winterfell to take down
bran Brean guard the castle together
with Podrick Jorah and ginjury Podrick
is killed off by a group of whites which
makes Brienne sad and angry at the same
time
Brienne takes out one of the White
Walkers with Oathkeeper mirror is urging
bran to give up and get inside but brain
doesn't want to he wants Meera to live
instead and get safe inside the castle
Meera answers that she'll stay
together with him until the end Jaime
Lannister and Edmure Tully with their
forces come to the North's aid right in
time
bran is managing to work into riggles
mind and the dragon starts to fight on
that Viserion trying to bite him right
in the neck but gets gravely injured
during the fight as well
regal starts to breath out fire on
Nazarian which seems to make the night
Kings start leaving the battlefield on
injured vegetarians back Mina realizes
that this is the end for them the White
Walkers are coming for bran and she gets
killed oh by the White Walkers all
defending brands body bazarian and Rago
keep fighting each other and both start
to be seriously injured it also seems
like Dragon Fire can harm the night king
the White Walkers step bran to death
which makes ragel fall to the ground and
to be finished by the whites the night
king's army is starting to diminish we
see Jaime commanding his men and
fighting the remaining undead alongside
bran Jon fights alongside the Hound in
Davos when John starts notice that a
knight king's army is retreating he
comments everyone to leave the
battlefield Jonathan goes dude I wasn't
around to get everyone safely outside
the Knights of the Vale Sansa Brian and
Robyn lived together to the Eyrie
Arya the Hound Jaime brought an end
mirror with the Tali in the lanes their
forces retreat to Reverend John Davos
denier Styrian Barristan sandy Joris ml
Gilly lil Sam Theon the remaining
unsullied and the detract forces travel
south Lyanna Mormont and her men retreat
to Bear Island in the last shot we see
John in the nearest on Jerkins back
setting all the dead of fire including
that Ragle preventing them from becoming
White's both sides suffered great losses
in this fight there you have it guys
like script for the second episode of
the final season and as always let me
know your opinion about all of this in
the comment section down below I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
one peace
you